what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are getting into really what
I would call the bath family Civil War I
mean that's kind of my stance on it
because it's that really seems to be how
it's being billed is like a civil war
among the bat family now this comes out
of the death of Clayface and that was
really kind of like the big thing that
sort of set all this off what are the
great things about how this story's
being written or really about how the
Detective Comics
run is being written by James Tinian is
that it gives us this really really
dynamic set of events with the bat
family and the sense of like Clayface it
had been like a long-standing Batman
villain who basically became a good guy
and one of the one of the things that so
many fans including myself saw was that
a time will come when he will like fall
back to being a bad guy but ultimately
when he was kind of tortured by ghosts
of his past so to speak and various
people in the course of his life some of
whom he'd really inflicted more harm on
than others what this meant is that when
the victims syndicate the first
quote-unquote victims of Batman and the
various villains that he faced when they
all banded together and you had like
glory who basically showed up who was a
former like really close friend of
Clayface who we also doused with you
know clay and turned her into a female
version of himself when you had like all
these things that kind of came together
it basically turned Clayface life on his
head and the result is that he descended
back into becoming a villain and so for
bat woman for Cait Kane her only idea
was well if we have to stop him so she
just shot him but she basically just
assassinated him with a bullet ah that
he couldn't recover from and that was
the end of him now likely he'll come
back I don't think he's really gone
forever but at the interim it seems like
he is and so because of the fact that it
was a member of the van of the bat
family that resorted to lethal tactics
in order to achieve their goal right now
it was you know really kind of the
aftermath was the trial of Kate Cain
this kind of follows that and it's like
what's the next step and so what we do
here is we initially pick up with the
funeral of Bruce Wayne's parents and
this was cool because this is basically
like Tinian you know kind of drawing on
the most recent legacy of Kate Kane and
saying like her and Bruce Wayne have a
lot of history together I mean one of
their cousins and two like they've both
lost their parents and they're kind of
in a position to where they're able to
identify with each other this kind of
creates a really shows the rift between
the two in the sense that you have Bruce
Wayne who would go on to become Batman
and it would sort of take the stance
that like it's not okay to kill because
one I don't want people to like feel
what I felt when I lost my parents -
that's a line that you can't come back
from you can't resurrect people and
three like villains have the ability to
be rehabilitated
whereas for
hate herself she's like well then let's
go find the people that did this and
let's kill him right off the bat she's
militant this is designed to kind of
juxtapose Batman to bat woman and say
how similar and how different are they
and I would argue with the exception of
the no kill rule there's really no
difference between the two but it is
interesting and it's and it's really
really intriguing so at this point we
jump up to the to the clock tower and
burn sideburns out of course being that
girl's place of operation and meeting
with Dick Grayson it's kind of funny
because it's like hey looked like I left
my vehicle in Bludhaven so I need a ride
you know so of course she ends up taking
him over to where Gotham City is one of
the other cool things here is we pick up
with Damian Wayne now Damian Wayne has
consistently been one of my favorite
characters in the Batman legacy like
especially now at super suns because
he's getting so much more development
that he had before and in this instance
he picks a fight with Cassandra who
essentially kind of like this super like
uber assassin the boat was raised almost
feral in the sense of like she was
tortured to almost the brink of insanity
by her father and then she doesn't
really have like social skills and so
not having any social skills means that
like she speaks in broken English she's
not really able to like create
connections with people and of course
you know Damian when picking a fight
with her means that she almost beats the
hell out of him which is kind of funny
because Tim Drake is watching the whole
thing unfold he's like I really kind of
wish I had that recorded because that
would be amazing
but this is the kind of coming together
of the various members of the bat family
you know of Jason Todd the Red Hood of a
bad girl of Dick Grayson Tim Drake
Damian Wayne like is all them just kind
of coming together because they've all
been brought together by Batman because
the the same and he makes is we have to
figure out what we're gonna do about
Kate Cain now the other half of this is
that while this kind of meeting is
taking place you've still got like
battling right like Lucas Fox you've
still got him you've got Kate Kane off
during your whole thing and what this
means is that lines are being drawn here
that in this conversation that Kate has
with with Lucas she's like you know he's
like hey look you know I'll be on your
side like I'm on your side on this I
think you made the right call
and I know Azrael would be on our side
as well what this means is that on one
side we have the bad family saying like
let's talk this out let's figure out if
something needs to be done and if
something does need to be done then
let's figure out what we need to do and
then on the other side you have Lucas
and you've got that woman and you've got
Azrael who basically say I figure did
the right thing or at least the
speculation is that Azrael would agree
most likely he would if those you guys
who don't know
Azrael John Paul Valle was a replacement
Batman during the
after the events of nightfall so that's
really kind of how he got his whole rise
to prominence at this point you know
switching back over to Batman and
company this is kind of a cool situation
because initially Dick Grayson comes
first and the idea is that with Dick
Grayson and then going to Jason Todd
what they do and even go from I Jason
Todd to Stephanie Brown going into like
like Batgirl they all start to raise
these really really cool arguments and
they start to raise these really cool
positions that Batman when he brought
them in by whatever manner and whatever
means when he brought in these various
members over the course of his role as
Batman the idea was he was working to
make the city a better place but also
working to make them better people and
it's kind of cool because with with with
Dick Grayson it's look you know like I
come from a background similar years I
lost my parents you took me under your
wing you tell me what it meant to be a
good hero you told me what it meant to
be something solid
Jason Todd says the same thing isn't
Todd's like look I basically died but I
understand what it means to take things
to the extreme well you guys who don't
know Jason Todd was the second Robin and
he was pretty unpopular with fans and so
DC ended up killing him off post crisis
and so following that like 20 years
later with Infinite Crisis they brought
him back and then they released a story
called under the Red Hood which actually
changed the manner in which he returned
but basically he was beat to death that
or not really beat to death he was beat
up and then blown up by the Joker and
then he was taken to the Lazarus pits
resurrected uh and then just like
trained to be an assassin and then he
showed back up in Gotham saying I'm
gonna destroy the criminal underworld by
infiltrating it but he was like like
DC's Punisher in a lot of ways but Jason
Todd's well Stan's is like look when I
came back here before I quote-unquote
returned to the bath family like I
killed people that's what I did and it
was the only thing that I was ever
really good at but like you've taught me
that there's ways to win without being
lethal but I would say the best argument
here probably comes from Barbara Gordon
herself throughout this meaning of sorts
people made different arguments in
different ways and you know you have
things like Tim Drake and yet like Jason
Todd for example so this isn't about
Kate Cain Batman this is about you
Barbara Gordon kind of draws that
together and Barbara Gordon makes an
awesome argument here what she says is
that Kate Cain is the closest thing that
Batman has to his mom to Martha and he
believes that you know in some some part
of him believes if Martha had been there
if Martha Wayne had been there that she
would have said Bruce take the shot or
like like Batgirl or a bat woman take
the shot it's the only thing you can do
Clayface is out of control if you let
him go more people are gonna die you
have to choose between the life of one
man or the life of
potentially hundreds of thousands take
the shot and kill him and if that's true
if Kate Cain pulling the trigger and
killing Clayface is what Martha would
have wanted her to do then that means
Batman's entire philosophy is out the
window is it's like his parents are not
really what he thought they were and
that's what this is about
that's bit me Oh Barbara Gordon says
it's a theory and she doesn't really
know if it's absolutely true but that
seems to kind of hit the nail on the
head right like Batman's entire life
philosophy is rooted in his parents at
the end of the day Bruce Wayne with all
the glitz and glamour all that kind of
stuff it's still just like a 9 or 10
year old kid crying because his parents
died that's it like that that was the
whole philosophy with like Superman
that's what you told Batman in injustice
he's like you're just you're still just
a little kid sitting in an alleyway
crying and you really believe you're
fixing things but if you were really
fixing Gotham City why is it still a
wreck and that's that's the arguments
being presented here like Batman's
philosophy resides in the fact that he
wants to keep gotham city protected so
nobody can go through what he went
through with his parents that criminals
have the ability to be rehabilitated
that lives shouldn't be lost unless it's
absolutely necessary unless it's outside
of his control and he's completely
unable to stop it but Barbara's like
Martha probably would have wanted that
to happen it's essentially saying that
like Batman's desire to preserve life if
at all possible clouds his ability to be
an effective superhero now this is not
like Barbara Gordon sank in order to be
a good superhero Batman you have to kill
everyone
that's not what she's saying what she is
saying is that it's not black and white
it's not an absolute it doesn't work
that way that sometimes you have to in
this situation it was like if Batman's
no kill rule stood didn't like it sure
they would have been able to defeat
Clayface but how many people would have
died in the process how many people will
have had to die in order for Batman to
preserve his no kill rule and then
ensure that like the villains captured
Batman's basically just sacrificing
innocent lives for some arbitrary
standard he created for himself and
that's the question that's being asked
here was Kate Cain right to pull the
trigger that's what's so cool I say yes
I say she was like at the end of the day
there's there would have been a
catastrophic loss of life in the city of
Gotham by the time they got Clayface
under control if they even managed to do
it at all because remember it's entirely
possible that despite Bruce Wayne's best
efforts there would be no choice but to
kill Clayface now Bruce Wayne's argument
would be yeah but we've exhausted every
other option so now we have to kill him
or as with Kate Cain it was like the
first reaction just fire the shot he's
done BAM he's out of
picture but it is cool because the whole
idea was that she was like I'm gonna
give you guys a shot do what you guys
need to do but I'm gonna kill him if it
comes down to it and that's the choice
she made and so Barbara Gordon's stance
here really Batgirl stance here is if
you can make an argument that like she
is legitimately out of control if you
can make an argument that like she's
crossed the line she can't come back
from then I'll fight on your behalf
I will fight alongside you guys but
right now all this happened is you've
had a member of the bat family who's
broken away from your no kill rule
because she recognized there is no such
thing as black and white that this was a
time worship where the trigger had to be
pulled in order to keep from having a
catastrophic loss of life and you're
just pissed off because no one wanted to
follow your rules that's that's exactly
the argument as she makes here and so
she's like that's not a legitimate
argument not only that she actually
makes a really really good case that
that woman is not like a rescue case
that woman came in because Batman asked
her to you know he was like hey look you
you know we've got history together but
you've also got military training you've
led people before and I need someone to
train the bat family in in my stead when
I can't be there I need someone to leave
that leave that group to work alongside
Tim Drake to improve the belfry and all
that kind of good stuff
and Batwoman could bring all those
things to the table but she wasn't Dick
Grayson but it's not like her parents
died and Batman adopted her she is
legitimately
on her own she does not have to exist
under Batman's purview and so Batman
doesn't really have grounds to put her
on trial or to kick her out or anything
like that she can decide to just keep on
being bat woman if she wants to and
what's Batman gonna do about it and so
Barbara Gordon's response is you can put
her on trial if you want to but she's
probably doing that herself and that's
when we switch over to bat woman and
what she's basically doing here is
literally tormenting herself going
through in sync I don't know if I made
the right call here I don't know if I
did there I think the character of
Cassandra was basically clinging on to
like any semblance of reality any
semblance of a meaningful life by having
Clayface there but he was the one
connection that she had to the world and
killing him destroyed that connection it
destroyed the one thing that they
Cassandra can generally say she cared
about and so because that like she's
torturing herself over all this and her
her idea is maybe I really am the
screw-up here like maybe I really am the
one that made the mistake and so what
she ends up doing is basically jumping
back in basically jumping back in with a
colony again is simply saying like I'm
back with a collie now essentially
joining their ranks and now here's a
question you have to ask if that's the
case are we gonna end up basically
seeing like that wing and all those
forces join up with the colony which
essentially she now seems to be the
leader of AI
if she'll be the one running the show we
don't really know yet well have to kind
of you know watch the Batman eternal
about an eternal story unfold I know
we're like one or two issues into it I
actually have been reading it yet I hate
to get caught up but it's still like it
is an awesome idea and it is really cool
because this kind of starts this Batman
family civil war but with that being
said guys we're going to bring this
video to an end if you are new here -
comments explained make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the robb core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace